we'll be closing out intersect today and
it is a meeting of brilliant minds our
own Sebastian run is joined by
entrepreneur and investor Marc
Andreessen co-founder and general
partner at Andreessen Horowitz for those
of you who do not know about Marc's
background Marc is an innovator creator
one of the few pioneers of a software
category used by more than a billion
people and one of the few to establish a
multi-billion dollar company Marc
co-created the highly influential mosaic
internet browser and co-founded Netscape
which later sold to AOL AOL for 4.2
billion dollars he also co-founded loud
cloud which has Opsware soul to healer
Packard for over 1.6 billion dollars
Marxist on the boards of eBay Facebook
Hewlett Packard amongst others and has
been an amazing friend of Udacity since
our early days please join me in
welcoming mark and Sebastian
[Applause]
[Music]
and look there's two minutes and seven
seconds left back up to the shortest
session of the day it's a an incredible
privilege and honor to have mark next to
me a person I really greatly admire he's
if you ever had an IQ chart from like
zero to 200 it would be 450 and he also
has the magical thinking kids foresee
the future which is actually very rare
but before I ask you a 1 a 1 1 of
applause to mark because none of you
would be here without him and here's why
in the early days namioka be confused
sorry this little company called
audacity in MOOCs I didn't rework I went
to mark and said I need money and Mark
said sure here's a check and without
that check there yeah all right
I I want to start with him with the beef
okay so mark tell me something in your
life you really screwed up so Sebastian
warned me he was gonna ask this question
and I told him I would answer it in a
way that was very disappointing to him
personally hopefully hopefully exciting
for the crowd so my favorite fictional
character my favorite series of novels
by a great American crime novelist named
Robert Crais and he writes novels about
these two guys Elvis Cole and Joe pike
and the character Joe Pike is a former
Force Recon Marine and like a really
really really tough guy and he has inked
his deltoids with two big red tattoos
with arrows pointing forward and his
life philosophy is only forward never
backwards and so I haven't gone so far
as to get the tattoos but that's that's
that's that's the program I'm on it's
good yeah I love it never backwards yeah
yeah I have a memory problem too it also
helps to forget yes yeah I mean and that
helps to forget them and also alcohol
yeah scotch scotch scotch yeah we should
get some Kevlar together okay so back to
normal questions that our team prepared
on tell this is an amazing audience kay
these are all students and graduates
Udacity they trusted us with their
careers and some of them got a better
clear and they came here to to learn
about us I think tell us how Silicon
Valley works yeah so Silicon Valley so
I'm a huge advocate for Silicon Valley
but that's because I'm an import which
is actually a really common thing in the
valley there are very few people who
actually very few people actually you'll
meet in the valley working in tech who
actually grew up here so and I'm kind of
representative of the imports so I grew
up and you know the rural Midwest I came
here after college and kind of
discovered it so I'm gonna I'm about to
kind of brag on it an advocate for it
but it's it's it's very much something
that I feel like I've inherited you know
that really sort of and everything that
I've experienced you know everything
that I've been part of builds on top of
you know 50 60 70 years of effort that
took place long before I got here and so
there's probably a couple big
characteristic things to it I think
probably the most important practical
thing is that it's a company town by
which I mean like it's a you know it's
all about tech and some people who love
tech love it here and people who don't
don't stay here that long most company
towns are dominated by a single company
and so in the old days you would go to
Rochester New York and it was all Kodak
or you'd go to you know these different
places it would be about one company in
the valley it's a company town but the
company is the valley and then the
individual corporations form and some of
them you know become very big and
important but everybody kind of I think
views themselves kind of as a member of
whatever company they're at but also a
member of the valley and that cuts both
ways for the companies because on the
one hand it means that your employees
are kind of always like well you know
there might be something you know more
interesting out there I can I can you
know maybe get a job at a different
startup maybe with you know bigger
opportunity and maybe not even have to
change my parking spot
so that makes retention difficult but at
the same time it's also the factor that
means that when these companies figure
out something good they can scale
incredibly quickly right and they can
pull in talent from all across the
industry incredibly quickly right so the
kind of the talent swarms around the new
opportunities and that's that's the
thing that I think is most
underestimated about the valley there's
always kind of predictions that the
valleys topping out and it's like okay
fine you know there was the micro
computer and then there was the internet
the smartphone but like at some point
there's gonna be something else well
actually at one point it looked like the
valley had lost the smartphone Wars
right Nokia and these other companies
had kind of wand and everybody said kind
of the valley the values best days were
behind it and and then it just turned
out that when you know Apple figured out
the iPhone Google figured out Android
you know the talent just immediately
materialized to support those efforts so
that's that's one really important thing
and that goes to the kind of Geographic
locality which we'll talk a little bit
more about the other I think is
psychological which is it's a state of
mind and it's something that kind of
everybody who's been here has had a
chance to kind of really enjoy it's
really quite amazing which is it's a
place that really rewards I would say
creative thinking and even radical
thinking and it rewards a level of
risk-taking and kind of danger in in
creating new ideas that a lot of other
places just simply won't tolerate and
and this idea that you know Steve Jobs
once said he's like you know one of the
one of the great things about the tech
industry is that you know basically
everything around you every tech product
that you have ever used has been created
by people who are no smarter than you
and so if you are if you put your mind
to it and if you get the skills required
to create these products you can create
products that are just as good as the
ones that everybody already knows
and the whole valley kind of has that
mentality it's possible to build new
things new products new companies yeah I
mean I remember I spent some time in
your firm that no leak went by no month
went by without meeting a head of state
or something that says how can I bring
Silicon Valley to my country
yeah right well why has that never work
yeah so it's kind of yeah we get these
kind of diplomatic missions and so if
they come by the way from other American
cities and then I also come from other
countries and and literally you know how
do I do and it's always Silicon
something right it's like silicon
Prairie or silicon Glen or London wants
to be so looking around about there so
like a desert I mean there's lots of
different kind of tastes on this and I
don't by the way they need to really
know like we don't actually make silicon
here anymore so you might right I
figured you could keep up with that kind
of thing so and then they say yeah how
can we build a new Silicon Valley and
then we kind of go through the you know
six seven eight steps that kind of got
the valley to where it is and then they
kind of get this kind of increasingly
stricken look on their face and then at
the end they say well what if we still
want to build a Silicon Valley but we
can't do any of those things
so that and then it's sort of you have
to wait like three years for those
people to turn over a new politicians to
get elected to them and then they come
back again totally different set of
people ask the same question so it's
what makes the place I mean and again
this this goes back to like these are
these are decisions that were made out
here in a culture that formed out here
you know 60 70 80 years ago I
hewlett-packard just down the street
from Hill at Packard you know Hewlett
Packard Hewlett Packard is a company
that was formed in 1936 and it was
literally put sort of the original kind
of founding company of Silicon Valley
and it was actually put it was it was
founded like in the in the middle the
Great Depression it was put on hold for
world war ii right like they literally
like put it in the deep freeze in 1941
they went off in fought world war ii and
came back in 1945 and like reactivated
the company right i mean like that back
when things were hard and so that
created a culture in a set of
circumstances that i think are hard to
clone aspirationally what i think is
possible what i so I mean it was pause
for a second
there are very interesting things
happening a lots of other places in the
world right and so notwithstanding
everything I said there are super
interesting things happening in a lot of
other American cities there's obviously
super interesting things happening in
countries China India you know
Stockholm's got a whole thing going on
London's very active like there's there
are there are more and more hot beds
throughout the world but I think that
big opportunity is not to copy Silicon
Valley I think the big opportunity is to
leapfrog the whole thing and I think the
way to do that actually is on the
Internet
I think I think the internet should be
the new Silicon Valley in the sense of I
don't think we should at this point you
know going forward I don't think we
should try to tie to any locality right
and I think we should basically try to
have the Internet be the global medium
the global place the global city right
if you will in which people can come
come together from all over the planet I
actually think there would be video
conferencing that it works yes yes
so yes yes no you made my day yes yes
that would be a good step one that would
be a good project is that hook up to
laptops use it would be good that would
be good maybe we can maybe after Google
gets a self-driving car
I'll finish maybe you guys could you and
your friends could come back on this so
I think it's an actually
videoconferencing is an important part
of it but it's also more about being
able to coordinate large-scale work
right and so it's being able to have
teams that people working together on
shared projects and things are getting
permanent one of the companies we're
proud to be another company we're proud
to be associated with is github right
which is like which basically is a
global marketplace a global network for
software developers and for software
code so you can see that's starting to
happen you can see there's these new
tools like slack that make collaboration
much more straightforward you know
they've got these you know the wiki
format for information sharing and so
you're starting to see these glimmers of
being able to kind of run you know could
say large-scale efforts of you know
significant numbers of really talented
people working together on a shared
project without having to be in the same
place and I think that's where we're
headed I actually think that also is
like a big part of the significance of
what's happening at cryptocurrency
which is I actually like Bitcoin in a
theory and these new cryptocurrency
things are examples of this like that I
think are actually playing out right now
and you can kind of see the future in my
view when you look at those things and
there's there's a couple of them now at
scale but there could be a thousand it's
an interesting area because if you look
at the fundamentals of Bitcoin revenue
and productivity and costs they should
have value zero and all of a sudden it
shoots up like crazy yeah where is that
going it is going to be placed
government's this is gonna what's gonna
happen
also Bitcoin kind of breaks your brain
so Bitcoin so literally this guy girl
team or a machine nobody's quite sure
Higuchi named Satoshi code we have to
name him her
theyõre itself Satoshi nothing for like
a week
wrote a white paper it's like a nine
page white paper released it in 2009
implemented the code distributed the
code and then if effectively vanished
off the face of the earth
in one of the weirder let's say it maybe
the best practical joke of all time the
most genius founder story of all time
you know somewhere in the middle and
this is a big deal right this person
whoever this person is he/she it or they
you know they're sitting on it's gotta
be I don't know today five or ten
billion dollars worth a Bitcoin so like
they're right whatever wherever their
volcano layer is they're doing fine
but like they vanished and then this
network gets up and running and now it's
this Google it's this global way to
store an exchange value that's you know
this is running in 180 countries anybody
with a phone can access it and it kind
of to the conversation for having like
it didn't there's no company like
there's no there's no office building or
anything you said that was it government
if you want yeah you're a government
you're mad about it you want to call in
the drones like there's there's nothing
to drone like there's no place there's
no place to go arrest people like
there's no there's no CEO there's no
staff there's no management team there's
no Board of Directors the investors in
the project are the people who have
bought Bitcoin right and in fact the
whole thing was engineered for the
beginning is very clever it was
engineered for a speculation to be the
bootstrapping mechanism to create value
right and this this is something the
press I think has a hard time wrapper
their head around cuz the kind of
conventional view of kind of financial
markets the speculation is bad an
investment is good but in this case you
had speculation that was kind of the
springboard mechanism to be able to get
to the point where it became an
investment and so it's kind of this
magical combination of technology and
incentives and economics and and now
having sort of set a template you know
there are now many many other efforts to
build similar kinds of networks which
the theorem is now is now a big deal and
so the fact that those projects are
being sort of done in this way where
they're sort of distributed internet
wide from day one and they don't
necessarily have a centralized team and
yet they have the opportunity to become
very important in the world right it's
really encouraging do you think that's
gonna disrupt governments and fun of the
spangs of governmental control currency
yeah and all of a sudden here's this
interchange currency that is out of
control I'm not that I'm not that I'm
not that discouraged on this point or
that I don't have to mr. kurtik screws
depending on your point of view for the
following reason which is we already
live in a multi currency world right and
so that you know you got
dollar and the euro and the yen and the
renminbi and then the you know on and on
but if anything you know you have more
currencies in the world today let you
know government currencies today
certainly than you did 50 years ago
right because you have more countries
right it's actually funny like the
number of countries in the world has
actually gone up for acts since the end
of World War two and it's almost like
nobody noticed and so there's more
countries there's more governments
there's more currencies and yet it all
kind of hangs together and part of that
right is governments within their
locality right they do have you know
they do have the ability to tax they do
at the bill to cover your house with a
gun and demand their share and whether
that share shows up as as dollars your
Bitcoin I think that in the long run
they'll be kind of ambivalent on but and
then I also think the benefits neither
side are really underappreciated which
is I'm a big believer that that sort of
the way you create economic value and
economic opportunity is through trade
right it'd be people being able to come
together voluntarily and be able to be
able to conduct transactions of
different kinds either Trant you're
trading goods or services or work right
in ways where both sides are better off
like I think that that's sort of the
foundation of economic growth and you
know the world is a much more open place
today than it was 50 years ago but it's
not nearly as open as it could be most
people in the world can't trade with
each other easily on these new systems
like Bitcoin and aetherium are gonna
make it a lot easier for that to happen
so I think there's a lot of economic
growth across borders that's gonna be
possible that is also going to generate
a lot of tax revenue I think there
probably be a big positive element in
that direction Maude you've started what
many of us believe is a leading venture
capital firm out of 2000 other
competitors and one of the things you do
is pick teams or companies to fund lay
out to us what makes a fund of a
community oh yeah so every venture
capital firm you you this is kind of
what you do every day is you try to
figure out this kind of magic formula
right and you see you know we see
probably 2,000 qualified like we see
2,000 kind of fully qualified pitches a
year give or take and we fund 20 or 30
and so it's it's a very and its kind of
relatively characteristic for the for
the categories so every every firm you
sit around all day like on Mondays and
you basically try to come up with like
okay what are the rules like how are we
going to decide what to fund and then
you see something and it doesn't hit
your rules and then somebody else funds
it and then two years later it turns out
it was Google and then you're like mmm I
think we need to rethink our really did
live
now by the way I didn't miss it we have
miss companies luckily our firm didn't
exist when Google got found it so that
that one is not pay there are other ones
that are more painful for me but not
that one
like what but no comment oh yeah enough
friends no one's listening you did you
didn't bring any scotch I will get you
nice photos so so rules are hard like
it's actually very hard to give any kind
of specific answer to the question I
think what you do is you keep falling
back on a few core principles in my view
so one is one is people and I honestly
think that's probably 90% of it and the
reason I think I was 90% of it is
because many of the big winners in the
for the kind of thing we do many of them
end up doing something different than
how they started and so the caliber of
the people you back I think really has
to be probably the key thing and then
the other two things you look for our
market you look for big markets you look
you look for Mart is sort of this
question like the wrong question uh
venture capitalist is this going to work
the right question is if this does work
how big could it get right and the
reason for that is basically nobody
knows how to do what we do without
having a high failure rate right so
you're gonna have a certain percentage
that just simply don't work and so the
ones that do work have to work so big
that they pay for all the ones
fundamentally that don't work and
hopefully generate some profit so you
can keep the whole thing going and so
you need the winners to be big which
means you need the markers to be large
and then you look for a technology or
economic change kind of you know in the
core of the company where it's like a
significant advance like it's something
where it's something where it's just not
obvious how a big company could easily
do it because there's something about it
that's a discontinuous Thep change in
the technology a step change in the
economics and a lot of the times what
that means it's just kind of a crazy
idea at the time right it's kind of an
idea that people just won't like a
really really positive sign for a good
venture bet as people daren't taking it
seriously like it's working like people
like the users like in cars but
everybody else in flying cars alright
what a crazy idea right yeah right
exactly right
and so you kind of look for it you look
for the craziness now the problem is all
the actually crazy ideas also look crazy
and so like flying cars
and so you can't you obviously you often
don't know right you simply often don't
know the other thing I find super super
interesting about what
and about what I think we all do in this
room everybody involved in building
businesses our tech of any kind
I become actually more of a Blee so a
lot of the commentary is always around
like is this a good idea or a bad idea
I've actually come around to the view
that like virtually any idea that gets
discussed in the kind of more than once
like any idea that's kind of in the
swirl you're getting written about it's
probably a good idea it's more a
question of timing and it's more a
question of like this decade the next
decade or the decade every execution a
bit an exit the execution against that
well is he it's funny so the I you know
the iPad right is obviously a big hit
for Apple and what people forget is that
Apple actually we're here in the
Computer History Museum and so I'm sure
they have one go see the Apple Newton
right which was the it was a tablet
computer released by Apple in 1989 and
it was a catastrophic flop that I almost
took about the company and if you
compare and contrast the Newton in 89 to
the iPad in 2009 20 years 20 years apart
it's basically the same product it got
skinnier right it got its color you know
it's got faster data like there's a lot
to it that's better but it's the same
thing right it's all the same promise
like they had all the promise in the
nude and they just couldn't build it
back then and so it's 20 years of and
then right is it did they execute how
much did they execute it better because
that you know Steve came back to Apple
and if they did a better job and how
much of it was just like you just needed
20 years to get all the components you
know you need to do the chip in the
battery in the screen and everything to
get better and maybe that was it but but
that like if ya just given what it is I
was actually a high school going to
college kind of entering this stuff when
the Newton came out and like the easy
lesson from the Newton is that's a
stupid idea and you know that was a
correct answer for about 15 years and
then a terribly wrong answer for you
know basically in the last you know five
years boy it makes it hopeful for Google
glass and give us oh I think Google
glass is a spectacular idea
you just need maybe you know a couple
more versions I'll beta test ok tell me
since boy I wanted I wanted you to go
into the future 20 years and come back
here and tell us what you see yeah like
what is gonna be completely nonlinear
surprising hot that you can see in
horizon nobody else can see so there's a
lot of specific ways to answer the
question I think the big one is the
internet city idea that I mentioned the
internet so
cities have always played this magical
role and how kind of civilization
develops and it's kind of if anybody who
like I did if you grow up in the country
move to the city you kind of see this
really clearly which is like the big
difference between growing up the
country growing up the city is in the
city you've got all these people kind of
slamming together right and you've got
all these things that happen when people
slam together including things that
people don't like but you get ideas
combining writing you get teams forming
and you you you literally get increases
in productivity growth economic growth
you get you get you get new idea
formation and it's it's really where is
where all its where art comes from it's
where culture comes from it's where you
know fashion comes from it's where
technology comes from as is getting
people together and so this idea you
know kind of my single biggest idea is
that the internet will be that the
internet will be a city and then it will
be the place where everybody can come
together and everybody can combine and
then you combine that with my other kind
of favorite idea which I call suffer
eats the world which is basically over
the next 20 years many different fields
of human activity and business and
culture and creativity are gonna go from
being not software to being software
right and actually it's happening
literally like right now in
transportation as a great example right
the car you know the car 40 years ago
was a mechanical device with a battery
the car today you know has like 200
micro processors in it and you know it's
computer-controlled you know throughout
the whole thing and the car and you know
in five years you're not gonna drive
because it's gonna be it's gonna drive
itself and so the the car becomes a
rolling computer right it's got many of
the same components increasingly as a
laptop computer and and the software
complexity and the thing just explodes
and then it can drive itself and then by
the way so I'll driving car you can then
recreate the entire idea of what a car
is right and completely change the whole
idea of the car and you can completely
change the whole idea of what it means
to travel right and say there's a
process basically the way I think about
it the process of software kind of
colonizing the car are taking over the
car and I think over 20 years I think
software takes over biology you know
software takes over healthcare software
takes over education which is a big
basis for our are you dancing investment
software takes over financial services
you just you kind of trip more and more
things over into being code and being
software and then you get the effect
that you see with software and with with
entrepreneurship and software which is
you get you know teams small teams a
very aggressive and hungry people able
to have really big impact right in
industries that may not have changed for
a very long time a good friend of a
friend of mine of all rava Kahn has this
great line it says every industry every
field of human activity every industry
that we know of today
they all started as a new technology
right the car at one point was a new
technology like the bank was new
financial technology and then at some
point like many of them they just
stopped thinking of themselves that way
and it just you know things just kind of
stabilized you know or ossified
depending on how you look at anything
yeah they just stopped changing but you
know they didn't have to stop changing
and they could change again they just
have to get turned back into technology
and so then you can have kind of the
Silicon Valley mindset or kind of the
tech software startup mindset and apply
it into these other areas you know and
many of the areas where that needs to
happen or you know hugely health care
and education right are gigantic ly
important all right and there we ought
to be able to you know there's seven
billion people on planet earth we ought
to be able to provide everybody with a
top quality education top quality health
care right at fractions of the price
that things cost today we're we're so
far from that today but we could get
there if we can turn these into tech
yeah we our students II came from about
a hundred plus countries and we have
several ten thousand students online
looking at us right now if you come to
your younger self what is the advice he
would give to our students so the single
biggest piece of career advice that I've
ever heard that I realized after the
fact I was implementing I didn't realize
it at the time was Scott actually Scott
Adams the guy who invented Dilbert easy
to remember who came up with this piece
of advice because how many how many
people invented Dilbert he his his big
advice was it's not about any particular
skill it's about combining skills right
the world is becoming an ever more
complicated place everything is slamming
together right it feels it used to be
discrete or not combining do a large
part to what we've been talking about
and so it's not about any individual
skill it's about come it's about
combining skills and then constantly
layering on new skills and so like the
great example is you can you can be an
engineer and you manage your track you
could be a writer the professional
writer but what if you're an engineer
with writing skills right and then you
can be the engineer who can then
actually articulate what engineers do
which might be helpful or you could be a
writer right who understands engineering
culture and you could write books about
technology right and all of a sudden
like both of those are like highly
differentiated skills like those those
are very special skills and then what if
on top of that you thread it in
knowledge of Education and then you have
the ability to write about technology
and education and all of a sudden that's
a very special thing
and then basically through the course of
your life you just keep layering in you
just keep you keep layering in more and
more skills we were actually I'll brag
on Sebastian you know professor turn
executive turned entrepreneur right it's
like no talk it you know talk about like
a magical combination of skills right
there's there's no possible professor
who could keep up with him in business
and there are very few business people
who can keep up with them on the
intellectual side of things and so the
magic is in the combination and and I
suspect the world's gonna get more in
the direction where combinations are
going to get much more valuable and the
people who have the combinations of
skills of attending on the students take
more than a degrees that's good time
would ask one last question sure how do
you get rid of fear how do I do what
fear fear seem so fearless what's that
yes that means what's that mean if ei
are AR see so much of it is it's you
actually actually read a study actually
read a study area there's a psychologist
named Dean Simonton who has studied the
history of creativity across every
different kind of creative field art
music and business and everything and
his his big conclusion out of the entire
thing is the people who succeed are the
people who just keep swinging the bat at
the ball over and over and over again
it's just repeated attempts basically
people who don't quit and who keep
swinging and so just it's just sort of
this I don't know maybe it's maybe it's
my Midwestern background or just
old-fashioned stubbornness but you know
it's it's very easy to opt out it's very
easy to get discouraged and give up but
if you kind of have the mentality which
I don't know where it comes from but
I've got it I've got the mentality the
basically says it kind of doesn't matter
how many times you get knocked down the
key the key thing is to just keep
getting back up and keep swinging and
the fact that actually by the way like
that that's Beethoven like it's not this
isn't like an absolute Steve Jobs
you know Steve Jobs like Steve Steve
Steve you know everybody knows Steve
obviously as the as the the guy who both
built in then rebuilt Apple but you know
Steve went through ten years in between
where he just got knocked down over and
over again and he came out the other
side not only rebuilt Apple but came off
you through said with Pixar as like his
little side project which is fairly
amazing and it was 10 years it was 10
years of working through you know
working through you know people just
just beating on him and so I just think
there's I think there's a real magic and
just
sheer stubbornness and taking whacks of
things and it goes back to the red dope
the red tattoos in the deltoid but you
know if you don't quit like they can't
make you stop you can keep coming
I want to thank you Mark I'm you
probably understand how amazing Marcus
Marcus is in my opinion the godfather of
singing valley today living and it's
such a great inspiration for us thank
you good thank you everybody thank you
[Applause]